hey guys I'm Brian right oh and I'm
Michael nerd Oh Oh Michael nardelie is
here with me today we're gonna check out
the trailer for Will Smith's concussion
okay cool
in my last video with Michael I was
talking about Will Smith balls honey how
were transitioning into this
you got it Segway you gotta check out
the last video to find out exactly what
I was talking about it was it was good
trivia I didn't know yeah no idea if you
ever want fact some celebrities genitals
just call me up you know all the movies
I know all the movies and which ones
have had photos leaked and yeah I know
the memo which one's your favorite
Brad Pitt because it makes me feel more
secure knowing he has a weird-looking
penis oh that's good Sony so needs to be
a comedy that's absolutely like to me
but I was wrong heaven was here
and America was here
you happy anything you could do anything
I am the wrong person to discover this
if you don't speak for them
I found a disease but no one has ever
seen repetitive head trauma chokes the
ring you turn on the lights and gave
their biggest boogeyman a name you're
going to war with a corporation that
owns a day of the week no proof was
presented today because there simply is
nothing they have to listen to us this
is bigger than they are
what do you think they're doing to your
Nana's it's nothing you have no idea how
bad let's go yeah if I have to keep
going they want you to say you're made
it all off they continue to deny my work
men continue to die
phileas jobs in life yeah leave it alone
I'm glad you came yeah
who are you tell the truth you didn't
answer his question the truth oh what an
interesting thriller hmm that's an
interesting dramatic thriller I wonder
who directed that no let's look it up
Peter
Landsman oh this guy dude yeah it was
Katie killed the messenger that's right
it looks like a good thriller I mean
that scene Will Smith in the with the
accent was kind of distracting at first
but as a trailer progressed I became
less distracted by it and how did you
start buying the images they were giving
us Will Smith you're you're tough
performance critic yeah Am I yeah you
think so yeah I know it personally from
not to bring this up again you know I
know I said some [ __ ] during the circle
trailer but I take it back after I saw
the movie I'm gonna bring this up in
every video ya know I feel like home
until I feel validated that you made a
mistake I'm sorry you didn't mean it but
Will Smith looks like he's doing a great
job I mean it really looks like the okay
Will Smith wants that Oscar this time
but I like this story they're exploring
here if this like brain problem that can
occur brain trauma I bet it'll be a dope
movie I think like with Michael Clayton
the trailer for that I was kind of like
huh and I love the movie I feel like the
trailer for this it's big it's a hard
movie cut a trailer for because we
probably deliberately holding a lot of
stuff back ya know I feel like the movie
will be really I feel like the movie
would actually be a really good time in
most
yeah it's very particular about choosing
his films I gotta say like even when his
films don't turn out that great they're
always at least entertaining yeah and I
feel like when it comes to his dramas I
remember Pursuit of Happyness
yeah yeah even that one movie that a lot
people didn't like including myself oh
the one with the there's like a fish
jellyfish or something some of the
pounds or size yeah but I always hear
about some scene with the jellyfish yeah
and
and there was I am Legend which I
thought he was fantastic yeah it was
great in that he did focus and then he's
doing a film like this I like seeing
that he's doing more movies that take
place in modern day because he's did so
much sci-fi for such a long time but was
that moderate as in the superior piece
oh yeah I'm not not modern might to not
be let me take that again let me take
that again let go let me take that again
okay it's cool the CEO Wilson is
actually your facts are on no I totally
feel you does if you're looking for if
you're advertising a modern-day Will
Smith vehicle this might not be in line
I think that this might thank you I know
I got my word usage incorrect seeing
Will Smith in app has he ever done a
period piece before wild wild west okay
but like a true story though and he got
an Oscar nomination for that yeah the
guy knows what he's doing and I love it
and it this movie really rests on his
performance it's one of those films that
looks like it's it's beautifully shot
I love the cinematography I love their
angles I like the yeah it looks great it
does feel like Tony Gilroy with a little
sprinkle of like a Tony Scott kind of
vibe Tony Scott kind of vibe for sure
like Oliver Stone it looks different
regardless yeah a lot of different ways
yeah I think it looks like a [ __ ]
sweet movie man hence the true I was
like this sports movie where are we
going with this trail and I don't know
the story you know I don't either
that's what I like I like a new story I
like some people are like you should
find out the real story I'm like I'll
find out the true story the fact I like
learning what the facts are after I've
seen the movie me too I don't like to
hear what like the movie is not accurate
to until after I watch the movie right
because it's much easier to accept the
movie on its own terms when you don't
actually know the story right and I mean
they always have to change some things
you know like they're never gonna do you
know it's not like a documentary that
fudged the facts a little bit yeah I'd
entertain as a nurse observers so of
course like after Beautiful Mind I bet
you got all up in arms because they
changed so many facts from that that was
a great movie what a beautiful mine was
100% accurate no you're gonna sound like
a total idiot right now Mike well it is
100% accurate everybody you know looking
up statistical fact is
everyone knows that my only concern with
this is that it feels like Oscar baby
like yeah that happens a lot these days
I feel like it does feel like since I
mean there's there's nothing wrong with
it doesn't it's gonna be a bad movie but
just that feeling of they're clearly
trying to get in the nominations right
now yeah yeah yeah something about that
always kind of distracts me because I
personally I don't know how you feel
about the Oscars but I kind of don't
care for them like they they don't
determine who is number one in my
opinion you know it's like no but I mean
it's good they expose like the
mainstream movie-going audience a lot of
movies that maybe they wouldn't see yes
they don't have that attention but then
there's so many movies I could ignore it
every year that should get Oscars and so
just getting this vibe from that is like
okay I don't know I don't know why I
have a problem that I'm just being like
a film school douchebag about her right
now
what was your favorite oscar-winning
film no a confidential Lord of the Rings
returning rings yeah thanks for giving
me my favorite and Alec Baldwin he's
making a big dramatic return in these
movies doing love smart supporting roles
of tough guys in suits do you like it I
like that it's cool because I loved him
as Jack Donaghy on 30 and he was so
[ __ ] funny and at first I was having
a hard time buying his transition back
in a serious film really yeah because I
know he started off as a dramatic actor
yeah but it was still like a lot of
these characters seem like Jack Donaghy
like head of something and they're
suited up and they're fast talking a
little cutthroat and stuff I really
start out a little bit of that Jack
Donnie
wink wink though even with the tough-guy
characters now like that's what I'm
saying is that the know is present no I
like it I think I'm buying it like I saw
him in Mission Impossible
Road it was awesome and he was awesome
yeah yeah anyway guys thanks for tuning
in to the Chanel if you're new to the
channel you can subscribe to the real
rejects Michael is one of the stars and
producers of the film I got to open at
Comic Con called circle look at this
shirt it's promoting third Oh
and that's gonna be release you said
October October October look out for it
it's a very entertaining film and it
also features Carter Jenkins Christmas
personal shadow Carter Jenkins we love
Carter Carter your cooled you I want to
tell you that it's Carter George nothing
wrong with it you can check out Michael
in circle and he's got a short film
coming out what's it called again
Dennis doesn't live here any Dennis
doesn't live here anymore it's gonna be
at several film festivals keep a lookout
for that and you can follow us on
Facebook Instagram Twitter vine
periscope I'll he's all for me he might
have something
Luke flux hi this is Luke flux I have
recently started my own reaction videos
good for you good for you we need more
of that and it's thanks to you guys that
the real rejects as you inspired me to
start it okay I'm glad I inspired you to
go into competition with me I'm nowhere
near as good as you guys are it's so
hard to react but I would really
appreciate it if you could give me a
shout out on one of your videos I'm
doing it right now buddy my channel is
literally just called Luke flux and the
profile picture is the terminator I only
have eight subscribers but if you could
give me a shout out I would be so
grateful thank you Luke flux Luke what's
let's see what you look like on YouTube
he's a British little [ __ ]
dude Luke flux Luke wood [ __ ] the [ __ ]
out of American chicks if you came to
California yes sir because the British
accent works on any woman guarantee you
100% guarantee if you talk to my
girlfriend with your accent she would
cheat on me right in front of them is it
true it's it's it's not her fault though
it's your accent she's laughing it's the
accent it's like triggers some type of
chemical and you're in their brains to
make them go okay I'm gonna hop on you
well so Luke flux is your competition
professionally then and personally you
know wonder [ __ ] Michael just got me
to realize something yeah I don't know
if you want to promote him no he's gonna
steal your followers and your woman
I will not promote Luke flux reacts but
we already have